it's a new week and that means it's time
for new releases and if you thought
there weren't enough zombies in your
life will then dead rising triple pack
has you covered you're getting the
original dead rising also getting dead
rising 2 and don't forget dead rising
two off the record this classic gets an
upgrade to 1080p and 60fps you can
really see the blood splatter the mall
is yours to shop to you drop make
smoothies and smash those undead heads
in in three games that are all
delightfully packed in a bundle it's
going to set you back 60 bucks but if
you just don't like one of those you can
buy them separately for twenty bucks
apiece it's up to you but you head to
the mall on the 13th keiji inafune a
sets up to the plate this week with
recore this action adventure focuses on
jewel atoms as she follows the voice of
her father's guidance and a group of
core box companions to assist her these
robot buddies don't just help in combat
they also assist in puzzle solving and
you can upgrade all six of your metal
bros by finding blueprints Scott puzzle
solving combat grappling hook a
heartfelt story it's got it all and if
you have an xbox one or pc this should
be on your radar on the 13th Bioshock
fans rejoice your time has come you're
getting the Bioshock video game series
it includes bioshock bioshock two and
bioshock infinite would you like me to
say Bioshock again Bioshock the newly
remastered versions of the three titles
are running at 1080p and 60fps this
includes single-player content
originally released as exclusives or
downloadable content packs including
minerva's den and a burial at sea but if
you liked multiplayer from bioshock 2
you're alone it's not going to be
included you'll also be getting juicy
commentary from creator ken Levine and
lead artist Sean Robertson these are
unlocked by finding collectibles
throughout the game want retail you got
it and it spread between two discs
you're going back to rapture on the 13th
here's a question for you what if Wally
was as good at murdering as he was at
being cute well you'd have arrived I
think rive is a 360-degree shooting and
platforming hybrid where you play a
little robot that could could what well
he could kill a lot of people you're
shooting it up in space on ships
underwater in spectacular environments
that are incredibly detailed and when
there's too many bad guys you can hack
them so that they're on your side when
you've taken everything down you can
collect their scraps and then you move
your little robot right along to take
down massive bosses with crazy
explosions that by all means should
entertain you i played this at pax and i
couldn't get enough definitely something
to consider and you can grab this on the
13th current-gen consoles and pc users
are getting NASCAR heat evolution that's
right heat evolves I was as surprised as
you you're getting all 23 tracks from
the 2016 NASCAR Sprint Cup Series
schedule you're getting dynamic AI in a
speed reading system that will change as
your skill progresses through out for
various game modes you get quick race
mode career mode Chase for the Sprint
Cup mode and challenge mode and in that
challenge mode you're racing the clock
against current NASCAR records good luck
you're off on the 13th speaking of
sports NHL 17 is coming out and boasting
improvements in terms of artificial
intelligence and physics you're getting
lots of various game modes including
hockey Ultimate Team a trading card
based team-building mode the
fan-favorite EA Sports Hockey League an
online cooperative play mode and a
revamped version of be the GM titled
franchise mode so many modes there's new
modes like world cup of hockey
tournament mode as well as draft
champions which is like a fantasy draft
style mode a newer creation zone is
added to the game featuring an expansive
team builder as well as an arena creator
most importantly all 27 teams are
playable for the very first time this
games similar to the past two NHL titles
features presentation style you know
like you'd see on NBC so look forward to
those commentators and your season
begins on the 13th
do you likee soccer well do I have a
soccer game for you pro evolution soccer
2017 is coming out on most everything
and features include among others
improved passing real touch ball control
and improved goaltending technique
you're getting fully licensed teams like
Arsenal Atletico Madrid Barcelona
Liverpool more you know there's a lot we
got them go soccer on the 13th you might
remember it from xbox arcade and its
back Pacman's sequel pac-man
championship edition 2 is going to be
released on ps4 xbox one and pc this
week sure you're in a maze eating dots
and avoiding ghosts you know the usual
but championship edition increases the
pace tenfold there's two halves the maze
and as long as you stay alive the faster
everything gets instead of levels you
just have a time limit so you're eating
as much as you can to increase your
score within the allotted time the game
features six modes championship which is
the basic five minute mode to challenge
modes which affect the stages you know
like a maze in the dark and three extra
modes featuring different mazes you're
also getting online leaderboards so
prepare to talk trash this is coming out
on the 13th and that's all I got for you
this week do you remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings
sometimes they change I'll see you guys
again not next week because i'll be in
TGS rob will be taking over have fun